à l'épaule sur vologne près d'epinal on
s'épie et en attend pour tenter de
retrouver l'assassin du petit grégory
la police doit faire faire des dictées à
une soixantaine de personnes et
recherche un personnage à jumelles
jean-claude d'arrigo examen
graphologiques de l'écriture des
suspects exploitation des traces de
chaussures et de pneus à proximité du
lieu du crime
l'étau se resserre autour du ou plutôt
des assassins du petit garçon on pense
que l'enfant a été attirée ligoté puis
jetée à l'eau par des individus qu'il
connaissait pour le moment la police a
des soupçons pas d'épreuve
ap des éléments que nous avons
actuellement je ne pense pas que le
dénouement sera très rapide nous avons
énormément de difficultés à progresser
dans un milieu qui est très
tout le monde ou presque secret le
meurtre semble-t-il a été soigneusement
prémédité l'après midi du meurtre un
homme à la jumelle a longuement observé
la maison des villemin peut-être le
meurtrier